what's going on guys I'm here to
resurrect a long dead segment on my
channel in the past I've made videos
called stuckman suggests yes I put my
name in the title because I'm that
egotistical but nevertheless I am
suggesting some people that I think are
really talented on YouTube people that
deserve more views and more attention
people who really are working extremely
hard on their videos and I don't want
that talent and that type of dedication
to go unnoticed now I want to stress
something before I get into talking
about these next three people none of
these people have contacted me none of
these people are paying me in fact I
haven't even told any of them that I'm
going to be doing this video so
hopefully it comes as a pleasant
surprise all three of these channels I
watch regularly enjoy on my own but feel
that they are underappreciated and
deserve a lot more than what they're
getting on YouTube the first gentleman I
want to talk about is somebody that I've
been watching for quite some time this
guy is really really cool his name is
John Maffeo I believe that's how you
pronounce his last name but his channel
name is Mothman Jones one of the things
that I really love about him is that he
really does have a lot of consistency
and I personally know that it is really
tough to see a lot of these big movies
that come out especially if you're not
even interested in them while also
maintaining a life because you have to
do things and then you had to go see
movies and you're like I don't want to
go see that but I'm going to go see it
and that's one of the things I loved
about his channel is that I can tell
there are times when he goes to movies
that he doesn't want to see but he does
it because he wants to make a video he
wants to talk about it another thing I
really do like about his videos is that
he genuinely comes off as a humble guy
and I think that's something to be
treasured because so many
larger-than-life personalities on
YouTube or in the world are in the
entertainment business they just come
off as these guys who think they're the
best and if I ever come off that way I'm
sorry I really don't feel that way about
myself at all and I can tell that about
John Maffeo as well he just seems like a
guy who really loves what he does I
strongly suggest checking out his
reviews because he's very consistent he
is entertaining he is very funny and he
genuinely does come off as a really cool
guy so John good luck with your videos
and guys do check him out I've left a
link for his channel below next person I
want to talk about is somebody that I've
discovered fairly recently but I've
really
enjoyed watching her reviews ever since
her channel name is roll credits her
name is Adele and she also does very
consistent reviews as well as television
reviews one of the things that really
really impressed me about her was the
fact that she can maintain a very long
portion of video without any cuts that's
not something I can say I mess up all
the time in my videos and she speaks
much better than I do she also just has
a very nice camera presence where she
doesn't come off as nervous or like she
doesn't know what she's going to say she
really comes off prepared and that's
something that's really to be commended
there's also not enough female reviewers
on the Internet that's something that
I've always tried to champion Adele is
doing really great stuff and as I said
similar to John very consistent and that
is something that I think is really
important if you are to be a movie
reviewer anywhere is that you always
show that you're willing to see quite a
bit of films even the ones you don't
want to see she does a lot of different
collaborations with other youtubers as
well which is very commendable because
she's showing the community that she
wants to take part in it and that's
something that's hard to do when you're
trying to figure out how much privacy
you want on the internet should you be
involved with other people you don't
necessarily know or do you want to just
kind of be on your own and she is
definitely showing yourself to be
someone who appreciates the community
that's something that's becoming harder
and harder for me to do because I've
seen comments where people tend to think
that I'm like this big guy who's like
always so big but you know I started
with 0 just like everybody else and I'm
just doing my thing here and I think
that Adele is really on a great path and
I really hope you guys do check out her
videos because I think she makes great
ones
the last person I'm gonna talk about is
somebody that you may go to his channel
and be like hey he's got 17,000
subscribers why didn't you give a
shout-out to somebody who had less than
that the fact is I think this guy's
under subbed I really do he's making
awesome very hilarious videos his
channel name is called fanboy flicks now
what this gentleman does is review
really terrible movies and he makes fun
of them in the same way that I kind of
do with my hilarious 'ti reviews and
what I love about this is he has such a
deadpan style of comedy and I mean that
as a compliment this guy has some of the
best comedic pauses I've seen on YouTube
he just has a good way of making me
laugh and that is one of the things that
I love about his videos because he takes
movies that admittedly make me enraged
movies like son of the mask and Jack and
Jill and he makes me laugh because of
them
that's one of the things that I can
strongly recommend him for is the fact
that he is able to find the humor in
making fun of such awful movies so if
you do like my hilarious T reviews this
guy has a channel that's basically
filled with that style of review and I
think that is really cool because he is
able to tap into that fanboy element of
a reviewer in which you approach a movie
on the level of this needs to be a
certain way because this means a lot to
me this character means a lot to me Oh
huge has made it awful well I'm going to
let you know how I feel about that he
does have 17,000 subscribers and he is
finding a lot of success but I think he
deserves more success because his videos
are extremely well edited as well and
that's something I think is very
praiseworthy with his videos guys those
are three people that I really think are
awesome on YouTube that are doing really
great stuff and I really want to give
more attention to channels that I think
deserve attention that are
underappreciated in my mind I really
hope you guys do check those guys out I
know there's a lot of under subs and
underappreciated channels on YouTube who
are focusing on movie reviews and there
are a lot of people nowadays that are
trying to do it as well which makes it a
lot harder for people to get noticed so
I hope that in some small way I can help
and I really hope that these three
channels get more attention because I
think that all three of them deserve it
guys thank you so much as always for
watching the links to those three
channels are in the description below
and as always if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck my next
[Music]
Oh